Marc Maron:  He pulls out
a little dime bag and
he snorts it and he goes, "You
want some?" And I'm like, "I'm
driving, this is not the time to
try heroin."
♪♪
Thank you everybody.
If you don't know,
here's what the
show is. It's just a bunch of
people and we're all telling
true stories.
You guys knows him from
WTF Podcast with Marc Maron.
Ladies and gentleman, Mr. Marc
Maron, everybody.
Alright so this, this
is a comic story. Now,
comedians, we have to, you know,
we have to learn how to be
comedians and that takes time
and it takes writing jokes, but
it just takes doing it a lot.
And a very important thing about
being a comic that you learn
early on is that if you're
booked on a gig, you better do
your time. No more, no less. Do
your time. Now when I started
doing comedy, it was in Boston,
Massachusetts, and when I was
starting out I was just starting
to work and the way the shows
worked at that time is you do
road gigs and the first guy
would do a half an hour, the
headliner would do forty-five
minutes and that was the show.
So now I'm just starting to open
and there was this dude who
moved to Boston from Cleveland,
no one knew who he was. All we
knew was that he didn't like his
name in the paper, he didn't
want his name on the marquee
because the IRS was after him
and an ex-wife. So this guy was
actually on the lamb doing live
stand-up comedy. These are the
kind of people that were around
doing comedy back in the day.
And this guy's name was Frankie
Bastille. Now I had to go pick
Frankie up to drive him to a gig
in Connecticut. We were going to
drive two and a half hours, me
and this guy I'd never met
before. So I go to this
apartment building and I'm
walking down this hallway to
pick this dude up and all I hear
from the end of the hall coming
from an apartment I can't quite
see is some guy going, "Where's
my tooth? Where's my fucking
tooth?" And I'm like, "What is
going on?" And I know on the
door and this dude opens up, he
looks like Keith Richards and
he's missing his front tooth. He
goes, "I'm Frankie, I can't find
my tooth." Alright, I'm Marc.
He's like, "Alright, we gotta
find my tooth and then we go."
Um, Alright. So we look around
for the tooth for about twenty
minutes and he reaches into his
pocket and he goes, "Oh shit, I
got it," and he pops his tooth
into his face. So that was
Frankie. He had a Tibetan chant
tattooed around one arm, he had
some other tattoos on the other
arm, he looked like Keith
Richards and he talked like
that, he's like, "Alright, man,
we're gonna go." So I'm driving
in the car with this dude and
he's giving the lowdown on how
to do stand up, right. He's
like, "Gotta do your time, man.
It's the most important thing.
That's the rules of the road,
you gotta do your time." And
right before I was about to go
on stage, he recited some poem
that he had written about the
road to me before I went on. I
wish to hell I could remember
it, but it was sort of like a
pirate shanty of some kind. So
now, like, I'm just starting
out. So I go on stage before him
at this place that had disco
balls, it was like just a bar in
Connecticut that was doing a
one-nighter. I go on stage, I'm
doing well, I do everything I
got. Every joke I have, I do all
of it. And then I stop and I go,
"Alright, thank you very much,
I'm Marc Maron, it's my pleasure
to bring up to the stage, he
works clubs and colleges all
over, Frankie Bastille." They
all clap. Nothing, he doesn't
come up. Clapping stops, kind of
slows down. He doesn't come up.
And I'm standing there, I'm
like, "Alright well, please
bring up Frankie Bastille."
Nothing. So now it's weird and
there's silence. And from the
back of the room I hear Frankie
go, "Twenty-six!" I'm like,
"What?" He goes, "You did
twenty-six minutes, got four
minutes left!" So I do some
street joke I remember and I get
off and he goes on and kills, he
gets off. He goes, "Gotta do
your time, man."
And I worked with him a couple
other times.
Frankie was a doper and this is
one of the reasons why I love
stand-up comedy because I worked
with him a couple other times.
And I was doing blow at the
time, I was doing a little bit
of coke. And he was living in a
SRO off of Kenmore Square, you
know, and I said I'm gonna go
get some dope, some coke. And I
went to my dealer's house and
somehow I left with like, you
know, a half a gram and a guitar
amp. He was that kind of dealer.
He dealt to musicians so it was
sort of a pawn shop-slash-- So I
show up at Frankie's with this
half gram and I was going to do
some lines.
He goes, "Can I do some?"
I'm like, "Yeah, it's fine." He
goes, "I'm going to shoot mine."
And I'm like, "Okay. I guess."
He goes, "You wanna watch?" I'm
like, "Yeah, I do kinda."
He pulls out like something that
looks like, you know, the kind
of, I was never a dope guy, but
you know when you got
paraphernalia. He had this stuff
that was like, "Wow that stuff
looks pretty well used. It looks
like you love that equipment."
And, you know, it was the
fascinating thing to me about
this particular moment is he
tied himself off and then he
pulled some coke into the
syringe and he hit himself. And
like within thirty seconds he's
like, [inaudible]. And I'm like,
"Oh no, now we're in trouble."
He's like, [inaudible], this
stuff's cut with baking soda.
And I'm like; I thought it was
so impressive that he could
taste from the inside. I
thought, "This guy is really
something. Real junkie." And
then he got all hyper and
started sweating and started
talking about things. But here's
the last bit is like, okay. So I
got driving down to Cape Cod to
do a show at a Chinese
restaurant called Johnny E's.
They had like a Polynesian dance
show and then they had comedy.
And I'm driving Frankie about an
hour fifteen, an hour and a half
down there, however long it was.
And we're driving and he's
pulling out little bindles of
heroin and he's snorting them in
the car. So like he pulls out a
little dime bag and he snorts it
and he goes, "You want some?"
And I'm like, "I'm driving, this
is not the time to try heroin."
So like he does two bags of
heroin and he's done, man. He's
out. He's like nodding, like
he's out. And we pull up at
Johnny E's and I gotta walk him
in. So I'm walking this dude in
and I put him in a booth and he
just was like, "Gaaa"-- out. I
don't know what the hell to do.
So I go up and I do my half
hour, I do my time.
And now I'm bringing Frankie up
and I don't know if he's even
awake. So I go, "Ladies and
gentleman, clubs and colleges
all over, please welcome Frankie
Bastille." And like a second
didn't go by and he bounds onto
the stage and he does the most
animated show I have ever seen
in my life. He's sweating, he's
acting shit out, he gets a
standing ovation. Then he gets
off, we go out to the car, and
he's like, "Gaaaa." And I'm
driving, all I'm thinking is
like, "That dude is a
professional."
[applause]
He passed away.
Rest in peace, Frankie Bastille.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
♪♪